il ya quelques jours je vous emmener
avec moi pour découvrir une nouvelle
tablette de samsung c'est la samsung
galaxy tab est 5e la question à se poser
c'est si vous recherchez une tablette
est ce que cette samsung galaxy tab est
5e est fait pour vous alors je vais vous
expliquer très rapidement pour moi c'est
une tablette qui vraiment fait pour le
multimédia pour un usage familial n'est
que vous pouvez pas extension ouvrir sur
un côté petit ordinateur
j'y viens petit ordinateur je vais les
grandes baies parce que vous pouvez
avoir un accessoire avec enfin tout ça
j'ai voulu montrer ce qu'explique vous
montre rapidement le contenu de la boite
je manque la tablette dans les bornes
franchement elle est assez intéressant
[Musique]
voilà la boîte sympa galaxy tab est 5e
bon assez standard a passé des heures
sur la boîte
le plus important c'est ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur alors là normalement on vous
aurez votre tablette qui est là dedans
bien évidemment je lui enlever sinon
elle est dans son petit étui à les
protéger
vous avez ensuite intérieur ici un bloc
de recharge rapide vous retrouver sur le
dessus de courir votre petit tiroir vous
avez un adaptateur ici à l'intérieur usb
tilt c'est vers prise jack parce qu'à
pas deux prises jack sur cette tablette
bon un peu d'eau qu'un intérieur très
rapide pour trouver ici un petit casque
et qui se branchent avec la prise jack
que vous allez branché sur l'usb tissés
avec des petits en bout pour vos rires
je trouve pas ça et pas pratique
j'aurais trouvé ça plus normal que ça me
saoule nous met un casque qui se branche
directement en usb tilt c'est plutôt
qu'à voir votre casque en prise jack
votre adaptateur
voilà ça c'est pas terrible terrible
pour moi ce moment là le mieux c'est
carrément d'utiliser des galaxies bugs
comme ça au moins vous n'êtes pas
embêtés ensuite à l'intérieur de la bad
vient trouver ici votre câble de
recharge usb type c'est vers usb et puis
voilà on a fait le tour bon vous voyez
je vous l'avais dit il ya rien de bien
d'un gars l'intérieur bac dans mastaing
petit coup d'oeil directement à cette
table est donc extrêmement positif avec
cette tablette c'est qu'elle est très
légère elle est quand même vachement
fine elle fait 400 g 5 5 mm d'épaisseur
vraiment bien on a un boîtier tout en
métal métal mass qui fait qu' on
n'attrape pas de traces de doigts
le toucher est sympa les finitions sont
vraiment sympas soit côté vous y
retrouve ici un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui bouton qui servira à
l'allumer et l'éteindre
et si votre bouton volume un micro pour
la réduction de bruit votre tiroir
proche de l'extension mémoire vous avez
deux haut parleurs signé à kg de la
recharge en usb tilt c'est ici vous avez
vos connecteur pwm débranchez votre
clavier de côté votre encore deux autres
par leur signer à kg un micro au poing
réduction de bruit à l'arrière une
caméra de 13 mégapixels que notre focus
nous finissions 4k uhd à l'avant vous
avez ici une caméra de 8 mégapixels et
voilà on a fait le tour le résultat est
vraiment sympa vous avez une tablette
les ailerons très facilement grâce au
capteur d'empreintes digitales vous avez
un grand écran de 10
5 pouces de diagonale avec une
résolution de 2560 par 1600 pixels un
écran qui occupent 80 2% la face avant
que je trouve très lumineux samsung
donne une luminosité de 500 dit ce que
je vous conseille de faire dès le départ
c'est d'aller dans affichage mais régler
votre affichage vous allez dans mode
d'écran moi je me mets en cinéma à
bollène francesca mieux par défaut il
est en affichage adaptatif affichage
adaptatif
je suis pas hyper five c'est un petit
peu trop saturé en plus avec beaucoup de
lumière bleue alors vous commencez vous
mettez en cinéma molette c'est beaucoup
plus douce et là vous aurez le meilleur
résultat
vous allez ensuite dans le filtre
lumière bleue vous venez vous l'activez
vous allez dans vos paramètres et là
vous venez cassé légèrement la lumière
bleue par défaut c'est quand même
beaucoup trop bleu vous venez vous
l'augmenter en fonction de votre confort
je pense que comme ça c'est là qu'on
obtient le meilleur résultat vous avez
lillers bleus qui est filtré c'est plus
reposant pour l'oeil autre point qui est
intéressant c'est la luminosité
adaptative en fonction de la lumière
ambiante venir régler votre luminosité
automatiquement ça aussi sympa qui a
plutôt pas mal bon pour les besoins de
la vidéo je désactive et je pousse la
luminosité à fond pour visionner du
multimédia c'est franchement hyper hyper
génial que ce soit des vidéos sur
youtube du contenu sur netflix ou bien
encore jouer à deux jeux vidéo en plus
qui coula tu sais que vous avez quatre
haut parleurs signé à kg d'eau par alan
ladd haut parleurs là vous avez donc une
qualité audio qui est très sympa le fait
d'avoir ces quatre parleurs situés de
chaque côté ça va vraiment devenir
spatialisé leçons ça c'est vraiment un
truc qui était vraiment très intéressant
d'autant plus qu'on est vraiment sur un
produit qui pour moi en tout cas
vraiment optimisé pour le multimédia
vous le voyez ne serait ce qu'avec la
forme de l'écran d'un écran qui garde
relativement allonger le fait d'avoir
vos deux haut parleurs de chaque côté en
vo quatre haut parleurs à kg c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment bien inspirés
de spatialiser à côté de ça vous allez
dans vos paramètres vous allez dans son
dansant vous allez dans paramètres de
son avance et vous allez dans qualité
effets sonores ça fait beaucoup de
choses et vous allez active et le dolby
atmos profiter d'une expérience sonore
qui est quand même meilleur après en
fonction de votre âge je vous invite à
aller sur alzette santé marais parce que
moi j'ai déjà passé dans la tranche 30
60 ans ça va permettre de devenir
optimiser le son pour corriger
défaut de votre oreille en fonction de
votre âge l'idée c'est quand vous
vieillissez vous perdez forcément des
fréquences au niveau de vos oreilles
souvent ça se creuse au niveau des
médias blessant qu'on l'entend moins
bien à d'absence va venir rattrape et
corrigée pour qu'on soit tous en eux
niveau d'égalité
dans l'absolu c'est pas mal c'est pas un
truc magique mais c'est quand même
plutôt intéressant je vous le disais
tout à l'heure vous pouvez le
déverrouiller avec votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales ça marche bien se
rapproche très pratique mais vous avez
également fait seul bloc
je ne vais en face ils me reconnaît et
il ya plus qu'a pousser vers le haut
c'est parfait ça marche très bien il ya
un poisson qu'il faut faire attention
quand vous regardez des vidéos a
tendance à tenir sa tablette comme ça si
vous tenez votre tablette comme ça vous
allez retrouver deux haut parleurs celui
là celui là vous allez forcément perdre
en qualité sonore
je trouve que c'est vraiment bien que
vous ayez 4 par leur match ne s'est pas
adapté pour le tenir comme ça
à côté de ça la qualité sonore est
vraiment bien et 4 parlera kg pour une
parfaite pour mes enfants
vous avez beaucoup de sont le state est
très bien personnellement j'adore mes
mots casque ça marche bien maintenant ce
que je vais regretter c'est ça voyez ça
pendouille c'est pas terrible
voilà ces trucs un peu limitatif à côté
de ça le bio est franchement bien elle
tourne sous le nouvel os de samsung qui
s'appelle own way manuel c'est vachement
cool parce que c'est une interface qui
est complètement repensé hyper sympa
hyper agréable alors vous avez toute la
question de données biométriques vous
avez toute la partie bien-être numérique
maintenance de l'appareil
vous pouvez régler pas mal de choses la
navigation est vraiment vraiment
vraiment agréable vous avez visa europe
toutes vos infos ici navigation par
geste je vous le montrez hop vous pouvez
venir monter enfin où un nuage c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est
complètement optimisé qui marche
parfaitement bien et qui vous permet de
profiter de la meilleure expérience sur
cette tablette pour l'usa je trouve
vraiment bien en termes de performance
par contre 510 absolument pas quel
processeur là derrière et nous disent
juste processeur octo cores on n'en sait
pas plus après vous avez deux
configurations soit 4 gigas de ram 64
giga de stockage soit 6 giga de ram 128
go de stockage dans les deux cas
extensible jusqu'à 512 giga pour
visionner des vidéos pour faire du
multimédia de base 4 gigas de ram 64
joueurs du stockage ça ira parfaitement
bien ci-après vous avez besoin de
stocker beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
musique si vous avez besoin de beaucoup
de stockage interne 128 gars ça peut
être intéressant à voir en tout cas la
grosse différence entre 4 gigas de ram
et si j'ai cadré un master au niveau de
la fluidité pour du multi tâche pour des
jeux plus gourmands
dans la poule déjà la première config 4
gigas de ram dans le cas des aires de
stockage pour moi ça ira très bien après
ça dépend de vos usages ça dépend de vos
besoins
voilà faut prendre un peu tout ça
rencontre là où elle est très très forte
c'est du point de vue de l'autonomie
vous avez une énorme batterie de 7000 40
millions terreur alors vous avez
forcément un plus grand écran qui va
venir consommer davantage que ce qu'on
va pouvoir retrouver sur un smartphone
donc fatalement c'est une machine qui va
plus consommée il faut forcément une
plus grosse batterie derrière mais en
terme d' usage c'est vraiment tout
simplement énorme
vous pouvez la garder plusieurs jours
alors une fois de plus attention ça va
vraiment dépendre de vos usages si vous
passez beaucoup de temps dessus à
regarder des vidéos si vous l'a
sollicité comme un ordinateur ça fait
beaucoup d'eux avec vous n'allez pas la
garde et plusieurs journées si par
contre vous la prenez pour garder un
petit peu de série le soir et nada mas
si vous l'a sollicité pas trop
l'autonomie elle est juste énorme si par
contre derrière vous l'a sollicité
beaucoup tout de suite
voilà ça va vraiment dépendre de vos
usages avec une grosse batterie de 7000
40 millions erreur vous êtes tranquille
vous avez de la recharge rapide il en
faut quand même pour recharger une
batterie de 7000 40000 intérieur donc
faut prévoir un petit peu de temps pour
qu'elle puisse se recharger mais de ce
point de vue leur tout cas l'autonomie
je la trouve vraiment bien on se passe
très vite sur la partie photo vidéo
parce que pour moi c'est pal usage
principal c'est pas usage courant
d'avoir vous avez effectivement
l'arrière une caméra de 13 mégapixels ça
me servira pour avoir des souvenirs pour
faire quelques petits photo bon voilà
c'est pas le truc le plus dingue
vous avez un zoom x 2 intérieur vous
avez bien sûr le mode portrait qui est
complètement logiciel mode pro panorama
vous n'êtes pas mal de petites
possibilités vous pouvez filmer au
maximum je suis en 4k uhd bon voilà
c'est bien pour des souvenirs c'est bien
pour faire quelques petites photos mais
c'est pas là dessus qu'on voyait pour
faire des superbes clichés sur cette
tablette vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 vous
pouvez l'appareil est très facilement
avec des galaxies buzz vous avec ouvrait
la galaxie bottes
elle valait reconnaître ça marche très
bien c'est très pratique vous n'avez pas
de nfc
de notre côté est ce que vous avez
besoin du nfc là-dessus et c'est un
produit que vous trouvez en version wifi
à 419 l'euro le vrai gros point fort le
vrai gros atout de cette tablette c'est
que vous allez l'utiliser comme un petit
ordinateur à la maison vous l'utilisez
pour visionner des vidéos
pour écouter de la musique ça marche
bien ça vous permet d'avoir une
spatialisation vous avez une vraie belle
expérience audio multimédia dessus pour
jouer à des jeux c'est aussi vraiment
hyper agréable alors le point de regrets
comme je voulais 10 et l'emplacement ici
donc si on pose sa main comme ça tout de
suite
on va un petit peu obstrué leçon il faut
savoir la tenir une fois qu'on a compris
ça y'a pas de soucis derrière vous
prenez un petit clavier vous pouvez
acheter en plus chez samsung
vous avez vos petits connecteurs vous le
prenez vous avez un petit clavier pour
faire quelques email pour échanger pour
naviguer sur internet pour moi c'est un
outil qui vraiment bien que je trouve
très intéressant je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez ce que vous avez déjà une
tablette de chez samsung est ce que vous
avez eu une tablette de chez samsung
et est ce que cette galaxy tab est 5e le
nom il y aura dire peut vous intéresser
je vous invite à marquer tout ça en
commentaire moi je trouve intéressant et
je vous ai dit j'ai regardé pas mal de
vidéos dessus je fais pas mal de
multimédia et je trouve que c'est
vraiment hyper confort est très
intéressant on va trouver d'autres
tablettes un peu moins cher mais sur
celle ci ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous avez quand même suffisamment de
performance pour votre machine
elles ralentissent pas ils vous puissiez
voir venir à l'avenir parce que une
tablette comme ça on va pas la
renouveler comme un smartphone
aujourd'hui le taux de renouvellement
des smartphones ces deux ans une
tablette comme ça vous allez à garder 3
4 ans 3 aucun problème donc à 419 euros
pour moi ça va ça fonctionne dites moi
ce que vous en pensez en main que si
vous avez des questions suggestions
interrogations vous invite à vous
abonner je donne rendez vous dès demain
pour continuer à parler tech vous
embrasse
[Musique]